our players can be some of the most hype
moments in any League of Legends game
and with so many game-changing and
legendary out players over the years
we've decided to look back at some of
the most memorable ones in League of
Legends coming in at number ten is
Suzie's godlike vein mechanics against
oMG during the 2013 world quarterfinal
right here comes the babe kill for white
Sam's I'm gonna skate it for big focus
our Uzi but look at him it's so much
it's Elsa baby he stays alive a royal so
what a baby right Oh already God right
there
our ninth spot goes to go soo pepper now
known as Edward and his three man
ultimate against SK oh no gage is going
to get close out here by also it will be
got to actually there to catch it does
use the aura t go through actually
popping his own oh dear oh my god can't
the salty back to with it grabbing the
eighth spot is Pee Dee Dee's perfect
Rumble ultimate during the 2013 all-star
event yeah it's already specially to get
some from the dogs but they are going to
go in up to Joseph he gets the box out
Julie will die from that he's hallelujah
pick that one up and help you want to
get out of here they don't want to fight
this one and why do they pack away will
they go in in towards the absolutely
water but they're all going to drop down
the equalizer if it's such a good fit
its second a registered pit that's a
date coming out for the uphill old dog
but look how quickly it can happen
EDD is so good coming in at number seven
it's forever lords legendary 3 ke lo
Orianna ultimate
against Giants during the EU LCS summer
promotion tournament
Sammy Santos was he part of a music
service it is very very bright it's
going to be our noise it's gonna pay
free with his life he goes south ends
gonna be also a is a great open a vegan
so that's why cuz it's all five members
of Giants s
beautifully does you're both gets drops
he's going to respawn he's gonna turn
back around he's firing off the Allies
just like you can Pharrell's or mix up
the double kill is still in this one
he's gonna 30 burgers
baramos-sama so it's gonna have to come
in another Paul goes in well you've got
to take it down
grants or picks up the kill and that was
a four four three two alternate stealing
the sixth spot is bakers for ke lo
shockwave against Katie proving once
again that Baker is a god maker has been
out of position because all right hard I
have position and we here in ultimate
pop can we see a turn yeah thread line
coming through people like us so
patiently does absolutely devastate the
rake the kt rolster a triple killer hem
pod trying to get out with his life but
it just doesn't look very likely it
could God on the back side of the
Baroness cake deep blow the game to wide
open Tony he led the dredge Lloyd pod
that door right will goes down Saturday
for SK Telecom t1 that right there is
the 4000 elo shockwave that is why faker
is the ultimate game breaker our fifth
spot goes to madlife's unreal thresh
play against mig blitz during the 2013
summer season it's going to be able to
have a chance to come back one suck
again getting part of it every single
one
how is that possible grabbing the fourth
spot it's flames amazing kenan ultimate
to save the team fight against najin
black sword on ambition maybe but they
wonder on the outside oh the right there
Oh miss Amelia pretty safe going on a
crescendo coming at a good placing
Maelstrom is it going to be enough Oh Oh
No members of knowledge is for jumping
left and right and CJ plays just ready
with the damage ready with that great
Canada lame way by huge right there
coming in at number three is insects
famously sent out play against EU during
the 2013 all-star events
play the match and the start of this
fight was just so key when insect comes
in behind junkie fuse in Ward back
kicked it that is so hard to execute
even though Europe tried to call
wouldn't mean really everyone to sit on
the rumble ultimate they'd already lost
their ad carry and they burned all her
seat feet really indication our second
plug goes to expec aid for his heroic
outplay now known as the expec a against
SK to win the tournament conceit is
given in that case definitely uphold the
necklace gently go guys he's trying to
do it there be more where the bait
decile find offensive interface janessa
so he won't get up he was
[Applause]
our number one spot goes to none others
and fakers insane 1v1 Zed versus dead
out play against Ryu during Game five of
the 2013 summer finals like even though
I only have a bat on the floor they give
them a bed opaque or maybe in trouble
your deaf art prize the queen up for you
oh look at the club's look at the boat
thank you why was that Baker with a huge
LASIK she wasn't I can't believe our two
song actually what that cool I can't win
a now Telecom options my sergeant issue
the Katie bullets base oh wow
can you say GZ those were our picks for
the top 10 most memorable out plays
League of Legends which one was your
favorite
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button